The first step to learning Ember is
to understand how routing works.
When an Ember app is loaded,
the router's job is to match
the URL against the list of routes.
When it finds a route,
it loads that route's route file and
renders the associated template.
Right now the base route loads
the application template, but
we can add to the list of
routes that Ember manages.
We can add a menu route that
loads the menu template.
Now, menu here and
menu here don't have to be the same.
This is what's matched against the URL,
and this is the name of the template.
We could just have easily have named
the template something like food.
So we have our application view and
we can display our list of menu items,
but we want to be able to
view just one item at a time.
There we go.
Now,
/item/strawberry-pudding will
use the item template.
That was easy, except what about when
we want to view the chicken salad?
We don't want to create a route and
template for every single menu item.
We can use Ember to make
URL matching dynamic.
Instead of listing each route
to look for, we can do this.
Ember calls this a dynamic segment and
will match anything between
this slash and the next one.
So the router captures the dynamic
segment and passes it to the item route.
A route file is where you put
the business logic for a template.
The template is then rendered
with data from the route file.
Awesome.